according to you Robin Hood needs his
band of merry men right hey youtubers is
charlie so big news arrow hundredth
episode Deathstroke is going to be
making appearance so there's gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on so they
make the Robin Hood joke you got to make
the Robin Hood joke every once in a
while but it just highlights the new
team this is rag man this is wild dog
this is Artemis so like some of these
characters we've seen before like we
know mister terrific we seen him before
we knew he was always going to become
mr. terrific eventually but now they're
just getting closer to their comic book
selfs like mister terrific is actually
going to be wearing the face pic like
the mister terrific face paint but they
all have some form of camo either they
wear a mask where they use guyliner or
you know like whatever it is to hide
their face just a little bit mister
terrific's face paint will just mimic
his comic book costume so it'll be fun
to see how they explain him choosing to
do that because normally someone would
you know they would just wear masks and
that'd be it but clearly something
inspires him to make the choice to like
completely paint a tea over his face so
it'll be fun but the real big news is
all this hundredth episode teaser stuff
that Stephen Amell has been dropping so
he just been randomly posting pictures
from behind the scenes for the past
couple of days just like every once in a
while he'll just roll something out like
hey look here's a guest star here's
caity lotz gang's all here of course
it's the big four night crossover so
they'll be characters from the other
shows as well as deep cuts because it's
arrows 100th episode
yeah sometimes I think to myself I
should just go to Starbucks like this so
the thing that everybody is going crazy
over though is this Deathstroke picture
that he posted now i don't know if it's
minus or if it's just an actor wearing
the costume or how they're going to
explain it but they wouldn't do this if
Deathstroke were not in the episode so
he's in there somewhere there will
probably be some sort of battle but if
you remember in previous season so you
have like season 2 Deathstroke full on
Manu Bennett Deathstroke beating the
out of team arrow at every turn
then you have the hallucination version
of death stroke that we saw during
season 4 where he went into the cave he
had this vision of darkness inside him
it was more of a metaphorical version of
Deathstroke like he was seeing all the
darkness inside him work itself out so
given that this is the hundredth episode
and there's some sort of twist that's
going to bring back Robert Queen as well
as Laurel we don't know if they're going
to earth-2 and this is going to be earth
to death stroke if it's going to be the
proper earth one Deathstroke or if
Oliver is going to be tripping balls and
manifests Deathstroke in his mind so
given it's the hundredth episode I you
know I tend to be more optimistic about
things like this especially at this
point based on what we've seen they're
not going to jerk us around they're
going to give us all the things that
we've been asking for you know with
albeit a couple comic booky twists so I
think that this will be a physical
version of destro it's not going to be
like some hallucination and as for where
he appears how he appears we'll just
have to wait for more teasers to connect
the dots from behind the scenes and when
we get closer to the actual episode
dropping in December they'll start
talking about it like oh you know here's
the synopsis so then we'll learn are
they going back in time are they going
to the future are they going to earth to
there are a couple different ways that
you could explain all the teasers that
we've seen the robber Queen one is the
biggest one like is this going to be
season one Robert Queen is Oliver going
to go back and see his dad from before
he blew his brains out or are we going
to see the green arrow Robert Queen from
Earth to which I feel like would be the
much better option so let me know in the
comments what do you think is going
on with Deathstroke in the hundredth
episode is he going to be chasing Oliver
down is Oliver going to be pursuing
Deathstroke or here's like the
fanfiction option so Stephen Amell
recently you know goes to lots of
conventions people ask him what's your
favorite team at like what would you
want to do on team arrow if you could
he's like I would love to have a destro
Huntress team arrow but because those
actors are always so busy it's just
really hard to nail them down like
Jessica to Gao is busy on another series
right now so is minus Bennett so they're
not available to shoot an entire season
so fan fiction wouldn't it be crazy if
earth to team arrow was Deathstroke
Huntress in Black Canary or black siren
because she's black siren on that earth
that would be the most nuts thing ever
like if Robert Queen just rolled up to
Oliver and he had like the full van dyk
like the Oliver Queen beard from the
comics just like the most ridiculous
comic booky Green Arrow you've ever seen
but even if they don't do earth to
Robert Queen I mean I'll be a little
disappointed I think what they're going
for when they did that on the flash was
the Thomas Wayne twist during flashpoint
like you have Bruce wayne/batman in
Maine continuity flashpoint happens he's
the one that ends up dying in Crime
Alley leaving his father Thomas Wayne to
take the mantle of the bat so on the
flash season 2 we saw like the news
broadcast of Robert Queen he's the one
that survived the island Oliver's the
one believed to be dead so Robert Queen
took up the mantle maybe he's super dark
and stabby like Thomas Wayne during
flashpoint but remains to be seen I'm
just I'm really hoping that we get to
see earth to and there was some dialogue
that Stephen Amell tease from the
episode where Oliver's talking to Thea
and says Thea we can't stay here so
either they're somewhere in time that
they don't belong like they're in the
past or they're on earth to but I know
everyone's still asking about flashpoint
changes on arrow they did say that
flashpoint would affect arrow a little
bit but it would be a really minor thing
in because the flash point arc on the
flash season three is being wrapped up
really quickly I think what you know
whatever it is that flash point changes
on arrow will learn about in that time
span 2 so first couple of episodes and
based on the way they've talked about
the characters I'm
not expecting flashpoint to affect the
Prometheus arc but new round of the DC
give away all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so what's going to happen
next is is there's new Doctor Strange
footage it does a pretty good job of
showing you what the magical battles
look like so I'll do a video for that
tomorrow morning also new Ghost Rider
agents of shield I'll explain the big
Captain America director of shield twist
because there's a really fun twist with
Jason O'Mara's character so be sure to
watch agents of shield sometime between
now and tomorrow and if you can't
believe it flash and arrow are coming
back next week the week after that is
when Supergirl on legends of tomorrow
are premiering so I'll just remind
everyone when I post more DC videos when
everything is coming back while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for that original arrow 100th episode
teaser and you can click here to watch
the super girl Superman footage again
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you